en él
félix
27 de febrero del año 2019 michael cohen
el abogado y hombre de confianza de
donald trump durante la última década
comparecía ante el congreso de los eeuu
su declaración fue toda una bomba contra
el presidente con él le acusó de
complicidad con rusia durante la campaña
electoral así como de varios delitos
fiscales además describió al presidente
de los eeuu como una persona racista un
estafador y un tramposo
en sí
[Música]
con esta declaración michael cohen
añadía más leña a un fuego que cada día
parece más vivo y que está a la espera
del informe final del fiscal especial
robert muller cuyas conclusiones podrían
desembocar incluso en la apertura de un
proceso de impeachment en la cámara de
representantes queridos amigos de visual
político mientras michael cohen
despotricaba sobre donald trump el
presidente de los eeuu se encontraba a
miles de kilómetros de washington en
pleno viaje a hanoi la capital
vietnamita para reunirse con el líder de
corea del norte kim jong-un en la que ha
sido la segunda cumbre entre ambos
mandatarios
en el sur
harbaugh en una cumbre que ha sido
tachada por la mayoría de los medios de
comunicación como un fracaso y las
preguntas que tenemos que hacernos son
ha sido realmente la cumbre de hanoi un
fracaso en qué punto se encuentran las
negociaciones entre los eeuu y corea del
norte atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vale hay excepciones pero en general las
segundas partes de una película no
suelen ser tan emocionantes como la
primera no os parece
y pues algo así es lo que ha ocurrido en
hanoi
apenas ocho meses después del histórico
encuentro en singapur
donald trump y kim jong se han vuelto a
ver las caras las expectativas apuntaban
a que en esta ocasión se llegaría a un
acuerdo concreto con plazos metas
objetivos
sin embargo la cumbre terminó de forma
precipitada sin que se llegara a ningún
entendimiento
por un lado corea del norte exigió que
se eliminarán todas las sanciones
internacionales a cambio de desmantelar
su principal complejo nuclear que no el
único el complejo de yongbyón un centro
dedicado a la producción de plutonio y
combustible de uranio para las armas
nucleares norcoreanas
por otro lado eeuu exigió que fuera
corea del norte quien diera el primer
paso desmantelando todos los centros de
producción y desarrollo de su programa
nuclear incluidos los centros
clandestinos para más tarde y sólo más
tarde contemplar el alivio de las
sanciones internacionales
como veis las posiciones no eran del
todo compatibles en la agenda norcoreana
no estaba renunciar a su programa
nuclear y eeuu no estaba dispuesto a
hacer concesiones a cambio de
prácticamente nada el dilema al que nos
enfrentamos es que los norcoreanos en
este punto no están dispuestos a
congelar completamente sus programas de
armas de destrucción masiva por lo tanto
otorgar muchos muchísimos miles de
millones de dólares con el alivio de
sanciones nos pondría en la situación de
subvencionar el desarrollo continuo de
armas de destrucción masiva en corea del
norte un funcionario del departamento de
estado al 'washington post' pero amigos
no os penséis que todo esto fue una
sorpresa no es verdad que donald trump
se las prometía muy felices pensando que
a cambio de garantizar un futuro
esplendoroso para corea del norte
inversiones y desarrollo económico iba a
conseguir convencer a kim hyun fijaos
nuestro equipo de los eeuu llegó a corea
para organizar la cumbre entre kim
jong-un y yo realmente creo que corea
del norte tiene un potencial brillante y
que será un gran país económico y
financiero alguno
kim jong-un está de acuerdo conmigo en
esto pasará pero lo cierto es que su
equipo era mucho menos optimista no es
ruido music tour y también vi kate the
bodies eres anual proyecto que implica
llegar a petzschner y pensión production
kate the bodies y casi el subirse
automóvil
espero que jean servat
tanto el secretario de estado- mike
pompeo como el consejero de seguridad
nacional john bolton ese señor con el
bigotillo habían dejado caer sus dudas
acerca de que se pudiera llegar a un
acuerdo
el caso es que esto es lo que se ha
contado en todos los medios y el motivo
por el que la cumbre se ha considerado
un auténtico fracaso pero espero algún
momento realmente fue la cumbre un
fracaso pues sí y no
[Música]
queridos amigos no nos vamos a engañar
ya nos conocemos todos en visual
político no somos precisamente lo que
viene a ser lo que se dice simpatizantes
de donald trump pero también siempre
tratamos de ser objetivos lo que no
quiere decir neutrales pues bien el caso
es que creemos que podemos plantear tres
motivos por los que la cumbre a
diferencia de lo que han dicho en casi
todos los medios de comunicación no fue
en absoluto un fracaso atentos
[Música]
objetivo vietnam
con más de 90 millones de habitantes
aunque puede pasar desapercibido vietnam
se ha convertido no sólo en una de las
economías de más rápido crecimiento en
el mundo durante las últimas tres
décadas sino también y cada vez más en
toda una prioridad para los eeuu si
puede resultar sorprendente pero estos
dos países protagonistas hace menos de
medio siglo de una de las guerras más
largas y duras que se recuerdan son hoy
dos importantes socios económicos y
políticos
[Música]
por cierto queréis una prueba de estas
buenas relaciones pues en marzo del año
2018 el portaaviones uss carl vinson
recaló durante cuatro días en da nang
fue la primera visita a vietnam de un
buque militar de los eeuu desde que
terminara la guerra en 1975 el caso
amigos es que la visita de donald trump
no tenía solo un objetivo sino dos
fijaos
la casa blanca aprovecho este viaje para
estrechar lazos con el gobierno
vietnamita trump se reunió tanto con el
presidente como con el primer ministro y
presidió un acto simbólico en el que
varias compañías aéreas vietnamitas
encargaron más de 20.000 millones de
dólares en la compra de aviones y
servicios a compañías estadounidenses
especialmente a boeing claro sobre la
mesa además está la negociación de un
acuerdo de libre comercio y la venta de
miles y miles de millones de dólares en
equipamiento militar
y es que amigos eeuu quiere convertir a
vietnam en uno de sus socios más
importantes en esta zona del mundo tanto
a nivel político como económico por qué
pues porque vietnam se está
desarrollando a pasos agigantados es un
país muy abierto al comercio tiene unas
relaciones poco amistosas con china y su
mano de obra tiene unos costes laborales
muy reducidos en otras palabras es un
país perfecto para inundarlo de dólares
[Música]
aunque no tengo claro cómo va a
sobrellevar trump el hecho de que eeuu
tenga un déficit comercial con vietnam
de casi 40 mil millones de dólares son
los misma mitad también unos ladrones
[Música]
por su parte vietnam aspira a recibir
todos esos dólares que pueden acelerar
su desarrollo su autonomía de china y su
posición de liderazgo en todo el sudeste
asiático
hanoi está desesperado por una mejor
relación con washington y le gustaría un
acuerdo de libre comercio con la
administración trump para garantizar que
no sea totalmente dependiente de los
mercados y consumidores chinos vietnam
también desearía comprar grandes
cantidades de equipos militares
avanzados a eeuu harry casey and is
director de estudios coreanos en el
centro para el interés nacional pues
bien qué mejor que darle a vietnam el
protagonismo y la influencia política de
albergar una cumbre de este tipo y si
además lo aprovechas para estrechar
lazos pues mejor que mejor no os parece
pues eso es precisamente lo que ha
ocurrido
[Música]
las cartas sobre la mesa
os lo hemos contado aquí en visual
político en un pasado vídeo sobre la
cumbre en singapur
[Música]
el concepto que corea del norte tiene
sobre lo que significa desnuclearizar la
península coreana es muy diferente al
que se tiene en el resto del mundo
corea del norte no tiene ninguna
intención de renunciar a sus armas
nucleares no al menos de una forma tan
fácil
veréis seguro que no sorprende a nadie
si digo que el régimen norcoreano es una
dictadura cruel con un historial de
respeto a los derechos humanos
absolutamente inexistente
aislado del resto del mundo y dirigido
con mano de hierro durante tres
generaciones por la familia del actual
líder kim jong-un hablamos de un país
donde sus habitantes pueden ser enviados
a prisión simplemente por ver leer o
escuchar medios de comunicación
internacionales un país donde cualquier
disidencia o discrepancia respecto al
gobierno que puede conducir a brutales
campos de reeducación y trabajos
forzados un país con un estado que
explota su propio pueblo enviándoles a
trabajar por el mundo en condiciones de
semiesclavitud
pues bien a pesar de todo ello las
ansias de donald trump por conseguir su
preciado acuerdo y su predilección por
los dictadores y políticos autoritarios
blanqueó en cierto modo las políticas de
pyongyang
todos están cuidando de sus propios
intereses nadie está mirando por los
intereses de los ciudadanos de corea del
norte de hecho os aseguro que a nivel
personal una de las cosas que más
deleznables me han resultado ha sido ver
al presidente de los eeuu regando la
oreja del tirano norcoreano os imagináis
que hiciera lo mismo con nicolás maduro
diversos prestadores
por lo elegante de indicar que existe
que se les fijó se la presencia en guamá
tipo de té dulce pues bien ahora gracias
a esta fallida cumbre las cartas han
quedado sobre la mesa el régimen de kim
jong-un no tiene ninguna intención de
renunciar ni a
ni a sus armas nucleares y que esto
quede claro además de ser un tributo a
la verdad le da fuerza a los eeuu de
cara a las siguientes negociaciones por
así decirlo ha bajado las expectativas
en casa algo que hacía falta
tuvo y además le ha dado fuerza a
washington en las negociaciones que por
supuesto van a continuar ahora del norte
necesita superar las sanciones y amigos
aún nos queda el tercer punto
[Música]
las reformas todo depende de las
reformas
amigos hace apenas 30 años vietnam
estaba en una situación incluso peor que
la de cora del norte hoy el país estaba
destrozado por las guerras sufría el
bloqueo de china eeuu europa e incluso
de sus vecinos del sudeste asiático su
economía estaba literalmente hundida
cerca del 70% de sus habitantes vivían
en condiciones de extrema pobreza
desde entonces las cosas han cambiado
bastante
[Música]
hoy poco más del 3% de la población de
vietnam vive en condiciones de extrema
extrema pobreza del 70% al 3 pues bien
el caso es que vietnam puso en marcha de
forma unilateral su plan de reformas
conocido como el doi moi antes incluso
de reconciliarse con la comunidad
internacional es decir mientras
continuaba sufriendo el bloqueo
económico de eeuu quien mejor ejemplo
para corea del norte quien mejor acción
que involucrar a vietnam en este proceso
y ponerlo como ejemplo que en pyongyang
sepan mejor lo que podrían llegar a
conseguir el éxito de la economía
vietnamita se debió a su decisión de
normalizar las relaciones con los eeuu
en 1995 le diría a nuestros amigos
norcoreanos que siempre que tengan un
conflicto con los eeuu no podrán
desarrollar su economía de manera
adecuada os lo hemos contado en varios
vídeos que por cierto os los dejamos en
la descripción kim jong-un parece estar
decidido a impulsar la reforma económica
y la apertura de corea del norte pues
bien que mejor que meter presión
mostrándole en primera persona el
resultado
ninguna tarea revolucionaria se nos
presenta aparte de la mejora de la
economía y la vida cotidiana de las
personas
kim jong-un amigos eeuu parece tener
claro que el problema norcoreano solo se
resolverá con una nueva estrategia más
enfocada en el comercio que en las armas
puede que la cumbre no diera el
resultado esperado pero fue un fracaso
ya veis que tal vez la respuesta no sea
tan clara como parece a simple vista
sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta la nueva
estrategia de la casa blanca no vamos a
invadir corea del norte no estamos
tratando de derrocar al régimen de corea
del norte estamos listos para un futuro
diferente es más grande que la
desnuclearización estoy absolutamente
convencido y lo que es más importante el
presidente de los eeuu está convencido
de que ya es hora de pasar página a los
70 años de guerra y hostilidad en la
península de corea no hay razón para que
este conflicto persista por más tiempo
por cierto apoyar la estrategia de la
administración trump hacia corea del
norte déjame tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
y por supuesto suscribiros a este canal
abisal político un saludo y hasta la
próxima